understanding the ethnic and religious
commonalities and differences in the
state or the region that used to be
Yugoslavia can be quite confusing but I
want to do in this videos try to give a
primer on it it's really key to
understanding some of the triggers of
World War one and obviously understand
the breakup of Yugoslavia which is quite
ugly in when the during the fall of
communism in the late 80s and early 90s
so first of all it's a good idea to just
understand where the word Yugoslavia
Yugoslavia comes from it's literally
referring to the southern Slavic states
so you go is referring to southern and
Slavia we're talking about the Slavic
states when people talk about Slavic
languages they're talking about the
languages they're spoken in this region
but also much of Eastern Europe and in
what is now Russia now what we have here
in blue is we have shaded in where
serbo-croatian is spoken serbo-croatian
which is the dominant Slavic language in
this region serbo-croatian and their
multiple dialects some people will say
oh it's Croatian or Montenegrin or
Serbian or whatever it might be
but most linguists say well they're
pretty close to each other and you can
kind of categorize them as one language
as Scerbo create Croatian and you see
that it's now spoken in modern-day
croatia bosnia and herzegovina serbia
and montenegro and that is kind of the
the commonality here the thing that ties
together this region now on top of that
so the Slovenian language is also a
Slavic language that is closely related
to serbo-croatian in Macedonia they also
speak a Slavic language it's closer to
Bulgarian but it has some close ties
it's not completely different than
serbo-croatian so you have this
linguistic connection throughout this
area now what divides this area is
really religion and history so this area
if you if you look go back hundreds of
years it was under the control of
various empires the austro-hungarian
Empire the Ottoman Empire different on
the austro-hungarian Empire you're
dealing with the Roman Catholic Empire
when you're talking about the Ottomans
you're dealing with a Muslim Empire
and they held different parts of this
territory for hundreds of years and so
what you end up is really a mix of
religions and that often gets tied to
people's with a what they perceive as
also their ethnicities and so what I
have here is kind of a breakdown the
religious breakdown of the state of the
former state of Yugoslavia so in this
pinkish color right over here I have the
areas that are dot predominantly Roman
Catholic and I say predominantly because
it really is all mixed together so
Slovenia Croatia primarily Roman
Catholic if you look at Serbia and
Montenegro primarily Eastern Orthodox
Kosovo Kosovo you have a strong Muslim
majority right over there and it really
gets and Kosovo before its breakup was
kind of part of Serbia and Montenegro
despite it having this very different
religious makeup and then Bosnia and
Herzegovina is where things get really
really mixed up roughly half of the
population and it's been moving over the
you know over the centuries but the
dominant religion there is is Islam and
in general and this is where it can be
confusing when people talk about a
Bosniak when they're talking about a
Bosniak they are talking about a Bosnian
Muslim Bosnian Muslim but Bosnia and
Herzegovina also has significant
fractions of Serbs who are Eastern
Orthodox so that's why I put the brown
here as well it's about a third of the
population and it also has a pretty
sizable Roman Catholic population or we
could say Bosnian Croat so just to be
clear here can be very confusing even
when you hear history of it or when you
heard it on the news I remember in the
90s hearing this other news and getting
very confused
if someone's referring to a Bosnian
Muslim or bosniak that's a Muslim living
in Bosnia that's what they tend to be
referring to if they say a if they say a
Bosnian Bosnian Croat Croat this would
be a ethnically Croat who is living in
Bosnia and they are they
it would tend to be Roman Catholic and
then if you have a Bosnian Serb Bosnian
Serb this is someone who I nicked
ethnically dident off' eyes themselves
as a serbian or as a Serb
who lives in Bosnia and Herzegovina but
is probably going to be Eastern Orthodox
so you can imagine you have these strong
linguistic and even of kind of ethnic
ties but you but at some point because
of the Lang because of the religion and
dialect changes there's also kind of
significant amount of differences here
especially when things got ugly as you
have the fall of communism so hopefully
this lays the groundwork of the
commonalities and the differences here
it'll help us understand what got us
into World War one or at least what
triggered Rover 1 and also some of the
ugliness that was seen in the early 90s
and just to finish up with a little bit
of context this was not a unified state
until you know World War 1 to some
degree was precipitated by a desire to
make this unified state these this this
ethnic grouping this really this
linguistic grouping tended to be broken
up with the austro-hungarian Empire the
Ottoman Empire entering into World War
one you started to have the decline of
the Ottoman Empire which started to
allow these people to start to have more
energy behind their desire to form a
unified state World War one was
essentially the catalyst that allowed
the the state of Yugoslavia to unify and
in different forms it stayed unified
until the fall of communist communism
and even though it was a it was a
socialist state a communist state during
the Cold War it actually always had a
kind of a strange and distant
relationship with the Soviet Union but
after the fall of communism that was
kind of holding it together these
especially these religious differences
frankly and these ethnic and religious
differences broke it apart